dude I saw a stone cold stunner an 82
year old woman and she lived yeah she
bounced back that's called being a
professional it's called knowing how to
how to execute a lethal move yeah but in
a controllable way
[Music]
you guys remember when that uh Jiu Jitsu
uh Jiu Jitsu coach was like rolling with
a white belt and he broke his neck are
we remember for 43 million dollars or
some [__] is there an update on it no
but there's something somewhat similar
there's uh in Azerbaijan you guys know
the martial art [__] [__] yeah [__]
instructor I killed a kid right
instructor I killed a seven-year-old kid
bro what are you doing what do you do
sit on him I think he's seven yeah he
probably suplexed alone uh yeah
seven-year-old in in training there's
actually video of uh oh my God I can't
watch it I can't watch it let's not
watch that yeah let's not I can't bumped
me out but in the video this dude is
like you know those videos where you see
a martial arts just slabbing all the
students like one after the other just
messing up I've seen a really [__] up
one yeah mcdojo like always like points
out how freaking stupid those are but in
this one he's doing that and they're all
kids and he's just jacking up each one
like super bad and then this one kid he
keeps picking him up by his head like
this
because a kid can't stand and so he's
forcing The Stand by picking him up by
his head why can't the kid stand because
he's [__] up already oh then leave him
on the ground yeah but like I think in
the video like 12 times he picks him up
by his head to prop him up standing and
the kid just keeps falling and he keeps
picking him up by his head yeah what are
you doing you [__] yeah why is this kid
in the [__] why is this kid in a car to
class he probably paralyzed him in that
class and now that he can't stand up
yeah because he was like slamming them
all and then like one of them just like
couldn't take it and then yeah that kid
ended up dying why is there video
footage was this like a special why is
there video please yeah like that's
interesting that they're recording this
no it looks like it's it looks like it's
a surveillance camera of the of the oh
it's surveillance so so he died from the
training yeah he did yeah he died after
the training yes just uh whenever you're
training kids just don't do that there's
no rationale for you to be slamming kids
on their [__] head maybe we should
just not Teach Santa
what's the difference what what's Samba
like supposed to be like well [__] is
more of like a Russian style martial art
but it's like they do there's an aspect
of them kickboxing they're in a ghee top
and then usually shorts on the bottom
but it's like it's like a hybrid of MMA
but with a ghee pretty much I just think
it's maybe a little too dangerous now
well even when you're teaching a kids
class like wrestling Jiu Jitsu at no
point in time is there an instructor
picking up and slamming seven-year-olds
it's like do we have to even say that
right like that is absolutely insane so
it's very short but without showing it
just you watch it and you tell me like
what part of this is not right
dude all of it bro you could tell this
guy's a [__] piece of [__] yeah did
you have anybody that in in your dream
that even remotely trains no dude you
can't do that to kids you can't do
absolutely do that what can you do to
kids look obviously you wanna sometimes
when you're teaching kids they're
frustrating and you want to like you
know rough them up a little bit or mess
around with them yeah but even when
you're trying to discipline them and you
can't do anything like that because
they're not going to learn that way
right like it's just I don't know that's
really [__] up dude they look like
toddlers they're really young dude
seven-year-olds they're tiny the way
he's handling them what the [__] he just
trips them he picks them up trips them
what the [__] is he doing he just keeps
like slamming each kid like like what is
the lesson here and that's why I'm I
think it shouldn't be tough
but there there's there's a lot of those
viral videos that Rob from mcdojo yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah and there's this one
dude he's just giant Jack like I think I
don't know what country they were in uh
but he just keeps picking up this one
kid he's probably a teenager and he just
slamming him overhead like and muscly
like not even trying to use technique or
anything yeah and he just picks his kid
up slams him picks him up slams him his
legs are going in the air and he's
getting slammed on the mat kind of
similar to this
but like this is also not some like
random coach he's he's the bronze
medalist of the European games
dude I saw a stone cold stunner an 82
year old woman and she lived yeah she
bounced back that's called being a
professional it's called knowing how to
how to execute a lethal move yeah but in
a controllable way
that's [__] sad yeah instead of
Samuel he should have done some
wrestling good old American style but I
I the thing about martial arts like this
kind of stuff and opens up the doors
for really [__] up things like this to
happen just because the type of
personalities that it might exactly
attract you guys are coming here like
hey Nick so I would like to learn how to
kill a man with my hands yeah bro it's
like you you get those guys for sure
there are people because to me like
learning grappling like this is a
responsibility in a lot of ways because
it is like it is kind of a superpower in
a lot of ways yeah but then
when guys learn how to do that they
either become really dangerous or they
become really nice you know and
especially when they're in a hierarchy
of authority as I'm the instructor I am
all knowing not for that culty [__]
comes into play so it's either like in
the martial arts world you hear stuff
about like sexual misconduct with minors
or or some of the female students or you
see abuse like this happen where someone
ends up dead or someone gets [__]
destroyed and that's why guys like Nick
Dojo are so important super important do
you ever see like in examples of these
things happening in schools or gyms
is it usually one guy out of a staff of
legit people that's kind of the ass or
have you seen whole places be this
shitty I think it's um
I think it's both like there's guys who
slip through the cracks yeah as far as
like one instructor that's kind of a
piece of [__]
and then but a lot of the times too
you'll see it starts from the top right
from the owners or do you think somebody
like like this like there's nobody
around him who could ever step up to him
like if he's throwing kids right right
like is everyone else is the culture so
far that like potentially right but then
again it's like is this like an after
school program is this like an actual
gym or like what what is this one guy in
a mat in a room exactly yeah but I I
think
it's so hard to draw the line because
like when me and Joe used to train our
Sensei was probably more like this guy
like he was really hardcore and he was
more from the like you just gotta stop
being a [__] yeah but he was tender to
kids I think there's a level of common
sense that he had yeah but with like
adults like he was pretty hardcore and I
can totally see like you know if you
have a guy that's like between this guy
and this guy and you're you're used to
seeing like a level of stop being a
[__] when you're 18. stop being a [__]
and you're 15. it's not being a [__]
and you're 14 and then if you're in the
[__]
in like the industry then it might be
like oh we gotta start making [__]
men when they're four years old yeah
this guy's like hey all ages stop being
a [__] yeah and then you're like what
the [__] are you doing with these
[__] kids yeah that's true you ever
see those videos of those guys they're
all standing in line
at a boxing gym or a kickboxing gym and
the instructor has boxing goes on and
goes up and he's just punching people
Everyone Gets a hit yeah yeah it's just
like is any part of that useful dude no
definitely not the karate ones are
funnier where it's like the dude I sit
there and the instructor's got like a
Kendo sword in the back and just hitting
them on the head yeah and he's supposed
to try and like either block it yeah
I've never belonged to an organization
where the master hits you on a vital
spot like body shots to condition your
body I've seen that I've seen like you
know I my parents showed me a karate
documentary because I really had this
Obsession they're like you sure you want
to [__] do karate this is how they do
it in Japan you know the kids um I
remember it was in Winter and they were
they were training and doing their [__]
inside of a creek inside of a river just
cold as [__] crying and [__] and then
that hyped me up and I was like that's
dope and then they thought that it was
going to do the opposite and make me
feel like scared but the fact is after
they did that they showed them in the
cabin warming up around a fire and then
they had that bonding around the the the
toughness right so I think like this guy
thinks he's doing that this guy thinks
he's like putting the kids in snow and
then like making them perform their
whatever
toughening them up
but this is this is just [__] up it's
abuse the um it's not teaching them [__]
the equivalent to this that I always
imagine is like a a Doggy Daycare where
like the worker is just slamming the
[__] out of dogs like you know there's
always one person doing that in those
places that like and it's because they
like
I think there's a good percentage of
them that are like bullies right who
just like and get off on that kind of
stuff right but there's also a certain
percentage of people who like have
episodes like this where they just
literally
lose their
their temper in a way they're just like
cuckoo they just go black right and they
just do [__] like this where they're not
but shouldn't they consider Banning
Doggy Daycare when that happens oh of
course yeah this guy should be in jail
for sure yeah what if this guy has like
CTE and he has he's having an episode
right here [__] with like like these
kids are trying to jump me bro I'm
telling you some of these people are
very unstable yeah they shouldn't be
teaching kids they're very unstable and
you know
depending on what and a lot of the
parents don't know depending on what
school they go to right yeah and they
don't know they sometimes they're just
not being proactive enough and they just
let their kids kind of be a part of
these programs but right if you see any
[__] like this well you're going off
like the rank of his credits versus like
that's what it seems like you know what
I mean maybe like talking to fellow
parents and being like how is your kids
experience because wrestling an ensemble
like this stuff and that and those
cultures are very like renowned like
they're very respected right it's part
of so much part of the culture and being
like a man and developing so it's like
this is very important to the whole
culture overall so if if but if I'm a
parent and I see this video of the way
that he's treating my kid that's I don't
give a [__] about any of that what if
what if though like you know how like uh
like we all grew up like with the with
with more physical like like what do you
call it punishments and [__] right and
then some of our friends that didn't
they think it's like crazy right what if
this is normal to them like what if they
grew up not saying that this is okay I'm
just saying their standards are
different yeah like what if it like
khabib wrestling a bear exactly like
what if they're getting the [__] kicked
out of them by their parents or whatever
right so when they come into this this
form of abuse that we see as abuse is
fine yeah who knows I don't know yeah I
mean that that could be yeah
but I think I think what I'm saying is
that less people will ring the alarm
yeah if it's normalized in the community
yeah so I mean if the kid hadn't broken
his neck or anything this footage could
be used as hey look how good this class
is Right Jesus Christ like this guy
means business he's going to turn your
kid into a monster like and some people
might want that even guys crazy even the
most hardcore guys in Dagestan who are
[__] [__] guys yeah they'll
definitely look at this video and be
like what the [__] is this guy doing
like it's it's just a bad egg yeah but I
don't know anything about Samba so I
just want to blame the sport instead of
the individual yeah and that's kind of
what I'm trying to get this whole video
that's comfy yeah it's much easier to do
that it's much much easier but there are
non-troll comments underneath these very
videos about this where people are
saying well the kid was just too weak
and guess what those people that are
writing those comments have never done a
combat sport in their life they're the
same guy or they have they're the same
guys who watch UFC and when a guy gets
knocked out they go he couldn't get up
this guy's a [__] you know like those
are the same guys yeah and I see Ryan
Garcia drop by body shot by Tank and
there's like yo you're quitting
if we can find all those [__] talkers
and remember that one Show the Bully
Beatdown oh I love that let's see how
they actually do in a scenario where
they're like talking [__] about this
person losing in the fight or whatever
let's see if you can take an actual body
shot from
um the guy that Ryan Garcia fought oh
exactly hey dude when I dropped 25 bucks
on the the Niners to win the NFC
Championship Game and Brock Purdy got
his little [__] elbow hurt and he
wouldn't come back in I was screaming at
the TV the whole time what a little
[__] he is you're ruining my [__]
life I'm like he has no heart he has the
problem is he has no heart but you don't
want to blame the individual you wanted
to blame the nation
well no no in this one I want to play
yeah because he lost money yeah because
I've been on third
[Music]
oh